what do you think about the ones that
are not officially licensed again like
the fan appropriations and fan art fan
stories fan rewriting I've long been an
opponent of fan fiction I then let me
define fan fiction very precisely here
because sometimes I get criticized by
people say you wrote fan fiction when
you were young and now you criticize it
how dare you I wrote what we called fan
fiction in the 60s in comic fandom but
that was simply fiction written by fans
right and and published without any
money and I certainly did a lot of that
but I never borrowed anybody else's
character or world I I invented I didn't
you know I was a comic fan I didn't
write about spider-man or Superman or
Batman I've created my own heroes you
know and wrote about then the white
radar and manta ray and garras and the
mechanical warrior and all that stuff I
was writing when I was 14 and 15 but
they were my own characters and my own
stories what fan fiction has come to
mean is writing Star Wars stories or
writing Star Trek stories or or writing
you know slash fiction which is you know
taking taking characters in putting them
together in unlikely sexual situations
and you know I don't you know what I
don't know it doesn't hurt me so if
people want to do that fine but don't
don't send it to me and expect me to
prove it or something well no fan art
that's that's fine that's a whole nother
thing fan art is great and people do
send me links to that all the time some
of this you just have to what you want
to do for your own amusement is great
but you can't start selling it on eBay
or merchandising it via then it you'll
get sued if not like me you'll get sued
by one of my multiple makers of
bobblehead dolls or figure you'll be
moving into one of the areas that
they're paying me good money to to be
into so and time did you have a quick
follow-up to that about what it means
for the publishing industry now that
again texts circulate beyond the actual
books that you're selling well I
basically agree with George that his
ideas are his ideas somebody you know
his characters are his characters for us
it doesn't have much effect because none
of it is very powerful some of it
creates good publicity and some of it is
annoying but frankly we don't pay a
whole heck of a lot of attention to it
so George for you I'm curious about what
do you what does that mean to you as an
author creating a fictional world where
that world now exists in multiple forms
well let's say it's been an interesting
experience to say the least I mean when
most of my career writing books like the
Armageddon rag and fever dream and dying
a light before that or all of my short
stories did there was no secondary
writes there was no subsidiary rights
occasionally I would get a movie option
you know most of which just paid me some
money and they held the rights for a
year or two and then you'd never see a
movie or something I did occasionally
get something filmed i novella night
fliers was made into a film at one point
I had a story called
remembering melody that wouldn't became
an episode of the hitch-hiker so
occasionally something came through but
there were no other rights beside that
but then with with when Game of Thrones
started becoming popular Song of Ice and
Fire
suddenly I started getting these offers
that I had never had before from various
people who wanted to do replica sores or
miniature figurines or you know various
types of games of role-playing games
paper and pen role-playing games and
video games and yes the wildering number
of things and I remember having through
a period where I said well I don't know
if I want to take any of these things
some of them seem kind of tawdry yeah
you know I am a serious writer we you
know would f scott fitzgerald have ever
had bobblehead dolls and then I thought
about it a little bit you know from what
I know that scott Fitzgerald he would
have sold bobblehead dolls in a minute
if they thought after them any money for
that so he and Zelda could have
continued to party so I signed these
various contracts and yeah I think they
both they've been good and bad things
about it you know I I didn't want to be
just a guy who signs that signs of
contract cashiers to check I wanted to
make sure that if I was go to these
products that they were good products
that they were true to the material so
initially I wrote in a lot of approvals
to all of these things that they could
they could do the game or they could do
the whatever it is but I would have to
approve everything and that sounds good
in theory but of course what had led to
me spending a lot of time approving
stuff and and not only probably giving
notes on stuff and I was probably a
little obsessive about it at first and
it wound up taking a lot of my time so I
I still don't want to let crappy
products get out there but I have pulled
back a little on the approvals now that
I know some of my licensees and who I
can trust and who I can trust but the
good part is that I discover that
there's an enormous synchronicity here
because I I've my readership started to
build from people coming in from other
avenues saying I'd never heard of your
series but I played the the role-playing
game and I loved the role-playing game I
thought I'd better look up the books or
you know I collected miniature figures
and paint them and I saw your figures
that Dark Lord was doing and I decided
I'd better look up the books so I was
getting new readers from from all of
these things it did cause a bit of a
bump but you know it with the HBO deal
which came along a few years later
because you know customarily when you
sell the rights to a TV or film company
they get all the merchandising rights so
HBO was saying well we here's the deal
and and we get all the merchandising
rights I think can't give you all the
merchandise I've already sold it to
these other people and what do you mean
we always get all the merchandising
rights and you know it wound up for a
time that it was look like the whole
deal was gonna fall apart because you
know even if I wanted to give them the
merchandising rights I couldn't because
I had pre-existing contracts but
thankfully my lawyers and agents were
found able to to iron that out but it
was a ludicrous nobodies ludicrous
negotiation a point where they're saying
yes but we'll give you keychains but we
keep bobblehead dolls you're going
through all of that with the with the
agent and well HBO is going of course
the I still have the old contracts that
are that are grandfathered in that are
still direct to me but everything that's
not under contract went to HBO so that
is just a flood of merchandising coming
out because nobody knows how to
merchandise like a television network or
or a film studio so there there are new
products coming out all the time
including some I never would have
thought like our own beer I mean it's
great we have our own beer it's terrific